what you're looking at is peat
it doesn't look very important
but it is now you want to ban people in
rural communities in my communities my
neighbor from being able to purchase
purchase a load of turf come september
and they don't have any other source of
heating they don't have any other source
of heat peat culture by the irish is
accumulated organic matter that isn't
fully decomposed it forms in waterlogged
oxygen poor conditions when plants die
without the fungi and bacteria needed to
decompose them
the places where peat builds up are
called bogs taking its root from the old
irish word bagach meaning soft ground
and it's in ireland where you can find
bogs like nowhere else
it's one of the boggiest european
countries that exists
and rural traditions in history are also
one of a kind
the earliest account of pead harvesting
is traced back to pliny the elder and
his work the natural history
in it he describes a group of germanic
people near the north sea coast of
germany who form mud with their hands
which when dried in the wind rather than
in the sun is burned to cook their food
and warm their bodies chilled by the
cold north wind
peat you see has multiple uses the ones
to remember fuel agriculture and
forestry
in ireland it's the first that has had
the largest consequences
the destruction of thousands of hectares
of bog
historically many poor rural irish
families would return to the same bog
yearly they'd be given terbury rights
the right to dig cut carry and take away
turf
there they'd collect the bricks of fuel
a slow burning earthy substance that
would heat their small homes homes built
in the same material peat is a good
insulator not merely a fuel
to harvest the fuel peat farmers would
begin with cutting away the dense plant
material and heather at the top of the
bog
and once they reached a sufficient depth
they would slice off the peat with a
tool called a slain schlon which could
also vary significantly by region and
country slains usually consisted of an
iron head and wooden shaft the head flat
and often featuring a wing which allows
farmers to twist the peat into roughly
formed briquettes which makes for easier
loading onto a barrow
the farmers would then bring pete to a
spreading ground where they would
arrange the peat in stokes small tipped
over towers that would let the wind pass
through them so that the sods could dry
evenly
but no bog is the same
in the polar regions of europe you can
find the pulsabog a bog with a
permanently frozen core of peat
distributed across the nordics and
common in finland
also located in phenoskandia you can
find the appaboog which is unique for
its concave and strength flark patterns
but we're focused on ireland because
it's the raised bog that we're the most
interested in
raised bogs occur in regions with high
effective humidity and with a high level
of precipitation narrowing its scope to
ireland england western norway the
netherlands and northwestern germany
although ireland has unique blanket bogs
due to a much higher level of
precipitation on average raised bogs are
still the most important
they're ancient pieces of land that host
some of the oldest ecosystems in europe
it's ireland that holds the largest
percentage of europe's active race bogs
and to understand why ireland does but
its other european counterparts do not
requires us to move across the english
channel to the netherlands where i
promise i did not intend to go but it's
necessary for the explanation
because where ireland's raised bogs
still survive severely wounded in the
netherlands they're practically dead
the dutch used to have one of the
largest raised bogs in europe but mass
reclamation in the 1700s resulted in its
destruction
peat is a heavy material so the value of
it as a fuel source had to be considered
against transportation costs and because
the netherlands had intricate knowledge
of water transportation the cost of
moving peat wasn't really a relevant
factor
but for the irish it started decades
nearly a century later the irish were a
rural population that was much more
sparsely populated and self-sufficient
also a product of the bog no boats pete
presents problems it's highly acidic
which is an obstacle for agriculture and
it's spongy which hinders transportation
and communication
that is until a great development
the potato
it seems like a boring root vegetable
root vegetable maybe but boring not at
all
it is high nutritional value can be
produced quickly requires little land
and can grow in harsh environments the
most important detail it originated from
the andes and it came to ireland in the
late 1500s and like no other european
country the potato dominated ireland
it was able to grow quickly in ireland's
harsh moist acidic boggy soil and
required less labor which created a
perfect storm that meant that the irish
population grew faster than its
continental counterparts and that
increasing irish population put an
increasing pressure on the demand for
energy
the potato combined with a bunch of
other important factors meant that the
rise of peat in ireland truly began
but a demand for peat meant a supply of
other things
bogs are carbon sinks if plants don't
decompose they don't release carbon
dioxide and extracting valuable
resources from bogs means you must drain
it cut through the bog and you get rid
of the water log conditions that make
the environment possible in the first
place
undecomposed plants turn into
decomposing ones releasing carbon that
would have otherwise been stored
and then there's also the little detail
that burnt peat is carcinogenic but
there's another thing that is lost
though much more difficult to quantify
a remarkable ecosystem
plants require nutrients substances used
by organisms to survive grow and
reproduce they require carbon hydrogen
and oxygen which they can get through
the atmosphere and soil but getting
other nutrients like nitrogen and
phosphorus can be a more complicated
endeavor especially so in the bog
mycorrhizae plants in the bog will form
a symbiotic relationship with fungi in
exchange for carbohydrates the plants
obtain valuable nutrients like
phosphorus
or swap out the fungi for bacteria furs
a common irish legume has a symbiotic
relationship with rhizobia a bacteria
that infects the plant's roots that
causes nodules to form in these nodules
nitrogen gas can be processed into an
actual useful compound but furs has even
more interesting properties it doesn't
only form a symbiotic relationship with
bacteria but it forms a symbiotic
relationship with ants
its seeds come equipped with an eliosome
a rich fatty substance that attracts
ants to move it back to their nests and
then there are the insectivores a
product of the acidic conditions in the
bog
sundews butterworts bladderworts and
pitcher plants each using their own
specific strategies to capture prey beat
sticky tentacles or intricate aquatic
valves that suck and prey in 10 to 15
thousandths of a second
but it doesn't stop there
sphagnum is a name of a genus of mosses
that develop in irish bogs a single
plant can hold up to 20 times their own
weight in water which is massive and
it's also the reason that it was used in
bandages to soak up blood
it's sphagnum that is able to grow on
top of itself compressing and causing
the development of peat it's not just
any plant it's a bog builder helping
produce incredible ecosystems most of
which are now practically destroyed
in the 1990s the eu passed conservation
directives that produced one network of
protected european habitats
to protect threatened species and
habitats and to promote respectful
tourism
forestry
sustainable agriculture and fisheries
all over europe
it directed member states to establish
special protection areas within their
own borders for conservation and in
ireland that was the bog
but protecting them was difficult turf
cutters in the west say they're prepared
to go to jail rather than abide by new
eu rules today they've entered their
fury in galway
this is the equivalent of the state
saying to me i'm going to take your kids
off yet and given them to a lunatic
they're not getting my bog no more than
they're ever getting my child
the message could not have been clearer
despite a blanket ban on turf cutting at
53 raised bogs in the west and midlands
turf cutting will continue no what
you're watching burn is actually the
outcome of farmer's protests in the
netherlands also caused in part by
natura
there's an anger there that's very
similar to the anger surrounding pete in
ireland an environment being harmed
difficult costs that now have to be paid
and wouldn't you know people getting
upset about what the right rules are
it's a consultation that is not no no no
that is not what minister ryan said he
came out he accepted he's accepted that
pete isn't just a clump of dirt it
represents a simple question as much
irish as it is european
how do you make the right decision
regarding scarce public land in europe
together that's an answer i can't give
you because i don't even know how to do
the dishes properly but there are some
people that i think can help
80 000 hours
it's the amount of time in your life
that you'll spend working and it's the
name of the non-profit that wants to
make sure that work is meaningful
when you spend days of your life looking
at an excel sheet with the sole purpose
of maximizing business metrics in a
company you're not truly interested in
it's very rational to ask yourself what
am i doing a meaningful life is a
function of the outcome of my actions
but my outcomes are producing
superficial power points not a life that
gets me excited i'd like to be solving
useful problems like pete in ireland but
i don't know how and where to start well
luckily 80 000 hours is here to help
solve your problem
it helps you find high impact careers so
you can help contribute to solving some
of the world's most pressing problems be
it through helping you find a research
position an internship at a government
program and are helping you solve the
question of ai safety a position my
brother and i have both considered
pursuing through 80 000 hours before
they even approach me to sponsor them
don't forget life is short your time is
something you'll never get back
but what you do with that time is
completely up to you please check out
their in-depth career guide at eighty
thousand hours.org
remember it's a non-profit their
services are free
thank you for watching